so when I think back to Daggerfall as a
gigantic world when I first played it I
thought like
I mean you're just struck by the the the
the immensity of it right the immensity
of the possibility when you're young and
you look into your future it's it's wide
open and you can do anything and that's
what Daggerfall felt like the openness
was gigantic
and Daggerfall is interesting coming off
Arena where Arena does the same thing
but Daggerfall in many ways is bigger
despite focusing on an area because of
how the density of okay this is how this
is how much physical game Space will do
for these Villages and towns and it does
feel endless even though you're looking
at a map that has constraints
and Daggerfall actually was a touchstone
for us going into Starfield
for how we do the planets
because there is
there's a different kind of gameplay
experience when you just wander outside
a city in Daggerfall
then you know follow a quest line and go
through go to this place and it's
completely handcrafted and everything
around every corner we've kind of placed
like Skyrim
you know starfield's a bit more like
Daggerfall and if you want her outside
the city
we're going to be generating things and
you kind of get used to that game Flow
different than we've done before and
fun in a different kind of way
we'll talk about Starfield so just for
people who don't know and how dare you
for not knowing but uh where with
Daggerfall we're talking about the Elder
Scrolls series that started sort of
talking about the big titles within the
series started with arena in 94
Daggerfall in 96 I didn't look up the
years before this this is depressing or
or awesome
um so all of these games
brought hundreds probably for some of
them thousands of hours of joy for me so
Arena Daggerfall Morrowind Oblivion and
Skyrim
so I don't remember arena being that
open world well it's all the provinces
it follows kind of the same pattern it
just doesn't have all the number of
villages and places that Daggerfall has
while Daggerfall focuses on the iliac
Bay
area arena does it all just changes the
scale in terms of
you know one block on the map equals
this much space there is something that
I mean I'm speaking anecdotal experience
but I I just remember it feeling
wide open Daggerfall it definitely was
the way Arena didn't
I don't remember maybe maybe because
Arena
it was so cool to have the just the
role-playing game aspect you're focused
on the items and the character
development you Daggerfall has a lot
more depth particularly in the character
system that's what it introduces all of
the skills and those kind of things
Arena
it's actually it's a game I love
um and it's very very elegant if you
look at the first one where it's just an
XP based system do this get XP level up
very classic role-playing game
um Daggerfall digs deep into who's your
character how are you going to develop
it what are your skills there's
advantages there's disadvantages and the
environment going full 3d
from Arena which is actually like a two
and a half D Doom style engine
um that I agree with you that Daggerfall
feels like there's more possibilities uh
when you're playing it were you able to
like look up the sky in Daggerfall yep
my memories yeah so that's what full 3d
means and then you can go outside the
city you can walk outside that says you
can do that in Arena too but it looks
more fakey right it's all going to be a
flat plane Here Comes things and then a
dungeon entrance is a you know 8-bit
here comes a little flat coming at the
camera